hi I'm no boy hello hello I'm Craig
Anstead and today we're gonna talk about
George Washington Crossing the Delaware
River
on Christmas Day so it's the end of the
year 1776 the Continental Army is camped
out on the shores of the Delaware River
in Pennsylvania George Washington is
like the Continental Army is it seems
hopeless
across the river in Trenton New Jersey
is the Hessians the Hessians are German
mercenary soldiers of the British Empire
and like hey man were cool and we makin
Zamani on December 23rd Washington
brings General Hugh Mercer who's a
Scottish general and general and Captain
Alexander Hamilton George Rogers like
look we have to attack the British on
Christmas night they're gonna be trying
to give me burping you know eating
that's the night that the least expected
so we get we have to move we gotta go
it's a surprise attack
so Mercer is like you know he's Scottish
guy so you know we don't have munitions
no I can do it
think about Sean Connery Oh
Mercer is like well we can't do this now
we don't have the provisions and
Alexander Hamilton's point of view is
hey that's exactly why we need to attack
because the Hessians have infinite
musicians no musicians they have
infinite infinite infinite munitions and
we can capture all that so all right
well this is what's going down we got
5,000 troops we're gonna cross the river
it's like 300 yards wide the
all right yeah we have to go full force
an attack which is fighting against the
British with their hired Hessian German
an army
so the Germans so the Germans all
right so it's a German Christmas
December 25th 1776 they're all
celebrating aids
this is celebration this have sausages
and sauerkraut
they're being festive they're drinking
an eggnog that's exactly what the
Germans were doing back to the three
platoons they all set sail across the
Delaware River mercer's Washington
Hamilton Mercer it's it's it's too much
snow too much eyes we have to back off
Jesus told me so so they back off you
know Hamilton's balls to the wall we got
to get across there man we got to help
Hamilton well we got to help Washington
I can't do it man it's too much snow too
much ice too much it's too cold
Washington says we're getting across
this river dude
everyone knows the story from the
painting the painting is like a pretty
picture of this there was a lot more
grimy and dirty than the period it's the
winds man blowing 60 70 miles an hour
little tiny iceberg smashing up against
this primitive boats that are made out
of cheap pine wood that's been mailed
nailed together with garbage nails it's
horrible
some of the soldiers have towels on
their feet they don't have shoes and
they're thinking hey man this is a
Christmas I should be a vegan
gingerbread man Washington's like hey
man it's the birth of our nation that
this is the birth of our nation I mean
it really is they may have a drink they
roll up up um Shore Trenton New Jersey
George Washington looks at the Sun and
he's like hey we're late let's
let's do this Washington and his
soldiers march into the fort of Trenton
and sure catch the entire Hessian
military off-guard
they start attacking the Hessians Hey
Merry Christmas mother they're not met
with much resistance they're like well
wait we need to fight but we're kind of
drunk and we're kind of like mistletoe
and jingle bells so by the time the
battle was over Washington had captured
over a thousand Hessians and only four
Continental Army troops had died and
then they looked there's all these
supplies and then in the corner there's
a pile of rum they all start pounding
rum getting drunk so when they took
these Hessian soldiers back across the
river after capturing them a lot of them
were drunk just putting him on bunks and
people are like falling off shit-faced
trying to get its history
[Music]
so this is the first major victory for
George Washington and his Continental
Army and it made an announcement to the
entire world that hey this Continental
Army is forced to be recognized you
can't you can't underestimate
[Music]
you